this question from discord imagine a  mrna vaccines eradicate sars kobe 2.  cautionaries and skeptics are likely  shunned and shut out from a scientific  enterprise thereby creating even more  rigid authoritarianism  or b  vaccines cause unforeseen catastrophe  and conspiracy theorists and traditional  vaccine skeptics claim victory trust in  the scientific establishment collapses  is there a way forward where science  doesn't lose  to support us like this video subscribe  to the channel and consider writing a  comment and because 1984 has captured  2021 click the link in the description  to see the full clip on odyssey  [Music]